rated everyone 10 and up
home world is unlike anything that's out
there it's a game about epic spaceship
battles to the spectacle of these giant
combat spaces the scale of the combat
you know just the number of them out in
the world it's just epic what's exciting
about a project like this is modern
capacity for technology to produce the
vision it was had
the draw of being a people lost from
your homeland and journeying across the
Stars trying to find your true home
there's something so pure and simple
about that journey
at the core of the story of homeworld is
this idea of this journey from working
hard being good but being
disenfranchised being isolated and then
this struggle through this almost
insurmountable adversity and then its
arrival at this place where you are
righteously and profoundly accepted and
included and if you are someone like me
or I think like a lot of our fans it was
like a perfect parallel for the struggle
that all of us were going through and I
think it's there isn't stuck with people
it's really of the video game industry
it's a real gamers game it was the game
that worked was the game that dead lived
up to his promise it's kind of
inspirational early especially when you
played as a kid and he saw this journey
happen it was unique for RTS and still
is unique for RT SS you know one of gear
boxes first franchises that we created
was brothers and arms and there was a
mode if you pause the game basically we
would go into a situational awareness
where the camera would come back and you
could sweep around so much of how we
engineered that and how we controlled
the camera I think was directly inspired
by the experiences I I had playing
homework I actually did not put that
together until just now when you asked
me that question as a child I loved the
original one just that that combination
of passion and power and
the depth to which the the combat
displays is striking it always stops me
you
you